on va passer à ce qui s'est passé ce
weekend a choisi le roi en banlieue
parisienne un enfant de 7 ans était
retrouvé dans un sac poubelle entre deux
voitures entre la vie et la mort une
histoire complètement incroyable 20h58
Michel est-ce que vous pouvez raconter
cette histoire à nos téléspectateurs on
a énormément d'éléments là-dessus vous
allez voir encore une histoire de fou al
c'est une presque une double histoire de
fou et vous allez comprendre pourquoi
vendredi euh donc vendredi dernier euh
des des riverins ça se passe ça choisit
le roi des riverins découv le roi c'est
juste dans valdearne à côté de vit 4 944
valdemarne donc des riverins découvrent
dans entre deux
voitures une masse sombre en réalité on
s'est aperçu que c'était deux sacoches
de vélo les grandes sacoches de genre
les sacoches de facteur et l'enfant le
corps de l'enfant était à l'intérieur de
ces deux sacoches c'était pas un sac en
plastique les riverins donc sont autour
de de cette scène
hallucinante l'enfant est nu ou
quasiment nu il porte juste un slip un
caleçon et il est couvert d'ématôes et
dans le même temps arrive une patrouille
de police qui avait été appelé parce que
à 18h et quelques un individu totalement
ivre est rentré au commissariat de
choisir le roi pour dire qu'il venait de
tuer un enfant et qu'il l'avait déposé
entre de voitures à tel endroit donc la
police allait sur place le type a même
insisté parce que le policier était
peut-être un peu sceptique en disant je
suis tombé sur un type complètement sous
qui me raconte n'importe quoi et le le
le suspect
présente son téléphone portable ou une
photo qui représente une main d'homme
qui sert le coup d'un enfant et à partir
de là on l'a pris au sérieux et c'est là
que la police est allée sur place c'est
là que démarre l'histoire et c'est une
histoire complètement incroyable Gill
vous confirmez tout ce que nous a dit
bien sûr c'est une histoire absolument
incroyable et quand on va voir le profil
de l'homme c'est hallucinant et les
parents en toute confiance depuis 3 ans
lui confient leur enfant rendez compte
bien sûr c'est inroyable il a été
retrouvé donc dans
des bien sûr alors cet enfant il a 7 ans
donc il a été découvert dans un sac
poubelle entre deux voitures enfin c'est
pasent un sac poubelle dans une rue de
choisi le roi donc c'est dans le
là l'F il est dans un état critique
alors l'enfant a un pronosticque vital
engagé les médecins l'ont placé en coma
artificiel pour éviter qu'il souffre
mais il était couvert d'hématomes il a
été étranglé une on a plus la preuve par
la photo il n'est pas encore sorti de
d'affaire alors on va revenir sur ce qui
s'est passé parce que c'est là que c'est
ça va vous alerter chez vous et je peux
vous dire que vous allez vous dire c'est
ça ça ça fait vraiment flipper qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé en fait alors ce qui
s'est passé les propos de du suspect
sont un petit peu incohérents il
reconnaît les fait il passe aux aveux il
reconnaît les faits il évoque un trou
noir il était le le le babysitur de cet
enfant faut dire donc c'est ça qu'il
faut dire c'était donc le babysiteur de
cette enfan 3 ans depuis 3 ans depuis 3
ans et les parents n'ont jamais remarqué
le moindre
problème et alors il y a quand même une
affaire dans l'affaire c'est qu'en juin
202 deux euh il avait été interpellé par
la police notamment la par la brigade
des mineurs il se trouvait dans un parc
en train de nourrir des pigeons il était
accompagné d'une petite fille qui devait
avoir à peu près 5 ans et une femme une
mère de famille observe son manège le
voit avec cette petite fille trouve que
la façon dont il est avec il se comporte
avec cette gamine il l'embrasse sur le
front sur la joue il la tripote il a il
lu met la main dans le dos il passe sa
main sous ses vêtements et cetera cette
femme va filmer la scène et à un moment
ce monsieur et cette petite fille
partent derrière un buisson et là cette
femme appelle la police il est
interpellé la femme remet la vidéo où à
mon avis la l'agression sexuelle était
caractérisée il était déjà babysitter et
il gardait cette petite fille il a été
placé en garde à vue à la brigade des
mineurs et très rapidement le parquet
pour des raisons qui m'échappent on
considéit qu'il y avait pas d'éléments
suffisants et ils ont classé l'affaire
sans suite on connaît la suite alors
justement la suite on va vous la
raconter puis que c'est vendredi Gilles
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé oui ben alors
donc apparemment le le babysitter et
l'enfant partent en promenade ils sont
en promenade donc il y a 3 km de
distance entre la maison et le lieu la
voie de l'épinette on le voit derrière
vous il sera retrouvé et à ce momentlà
effectivement il y a ce geste d'une
brutalité incroyable que le suspect
décrit comme un coup de folie
inexplicable c'est-à-dire qu'il tente
tout simplement d'étrangler l'enfant il
veut étrangler l'enfant qu'il gardait
depajout qu j'ajoute quand même que cet
enfant est retrouvé en caleçon on est au
mois de novembre il est pas sorti dans
cette tenue de chez lui donc quand on
relit l'affaire de juin 2022 qui a été
classé sans suite par le parquet et et
les circonstances dans lesquelles on
découvre le le corps de cet enfant il
est clair qu' y a une connotation
sexuelle dans cette histoire alors donc
il a quoi il est sorti en calç son avec
le petit oui alors est-ce qu'il y a eu
une agression sexuelle déjà au domicile
est-ce qu'il y a eu quelque chose là
pour le moment le le le suspect c'est
rendu de lui-même mais les enquêteurs
vont devoir déterminer ce qui s'est
passé le profil comme disait Michel de
de du suspect est incroyable il se
présente comme auxiliaire parental
auto-entrepreneur on a vu cette première
affaire avec un classement sans suite
pour absence d'infraction et là il
récidive ça pose quand même a 29 ans
alors c'était le babysitter de l'enfant
oui oui depuis 3 ans depuis 3 ans est-ce
qu'il y avait déjà eu des problèmes
Michel absol pas les parents ont été
entend par la police judiciire et il ils
ne disent il ne déclarent aucun aucun
moment qui a eu un problème l'enfant n'a
rien dit l'enfant ne s'est pas plain et
les parents n'ont absolument rien
remarqué alors après on sait pas ce qui
s'est passé estce qui peut-être qu'il
s'est rien passé d'ailleurs avant et que
c'est un pétage de plomb ce jour-là ils
étaient en totale confiance avec le
babyitter les voisins décrivent cette
famille charmante mais pas de problème
non plus avec ce ce babysit donc que
s'est-il passé est-ce que c'était
prémédité est-ce que c'est un coup de
folie voilà alors justement on va
revenir sur les parents et sur ce qui
s'est passé vendredi à 21h05 euh les
parents donc rentrent chez eux et ils ne
trouvent pas leur enfant ch qu'on leur
raconte cette histoire à 21h05 Michel et
Gill oui bah quand les parents sont
rentrés chez eux la maison était vide
pas d'enfant pas de d'auxiliaire
parental donc très vite ils ont ils onts
ont cherché aux alentours ils ont pas
trouvé et très vite ils vont au
commissariat de de police lequel
commissariat de police était déjà alors
c'est pas la la même ville mais c'est on
est à Vitri sur scène pour le domicile
des parents de l'enfant et a choisi le
roi pour pour la la découverte des faits
mais entre les deux commissariats c'est
le même département et ça communique et
quand on retrouve un enfant dans cet
état-là forcément sur tout le
département ça se sait et du coup bah le
lien a été immédiatement fait les
parents quand ils arrivent au
commissariat de police en disant voilà
mon fils mon fils a disparu il était
avec un son babysitter et et je n'ai pas
de nouvelles les policiers font le
rapprochement avec alors justement parce
que quand il arrive au commissariat donc
peu avant 18h donc un homme serend au
commissariat choisi le roi il a 29 ans
il se dit atteint de trouble manteaux et
son pantalon est rempli de sang il dit
je veux avouer j'ai tué un enfant donc
là et il montre la photo il montre la
photo stupéfaction chez les policiers il
a tué comment il dit quoi il a tué
comment en fait il il est pas mort ou je
sais non mais non mais non il a voulu le
tuer comment il raconte tout hein il
raconte qu'il a voulu l'étrangler il
raconte ça il montre la voilà il anglais
et il l'a couvert de coup il a il le
corps était recouvert d'ématôes mais
pourquoi il a fait ça alors c'est
justement tout le problème il ne
s'explique pas sur ce point euh moi je
dis une fois de plus que la la tenue
vestimentaire de l'enfant m'amène à
penser qu'il a une un caractère sexuel
dans cette agression d'autant que il
avait déjà dans le passé une petite
histoire qui ressemble un petit peu à ça
c'est c'est il y a des
je vais très loin mais je pense à Lola
en parlant en pensant à cette
histoire je pense à Lola quoi parce que
c'est un petit peu le même profil bon
Lola c'était une femme qui l'avait
agressé là c'est un homme mais on est un
peu dans ces rapports adultes enfant
adulte bah 29 ans célibataire pas de vie
sociale pas de vie sexuelle tous les
tous les parents qui nous regarde là qui
ont des babysitter même depuis longtemps
ils vont être je vous dis là ils vont
être terrifiés parce que il arrive au
commissariat il voit les policiers
écoutez bien il dit il affirme je cite
je mérite d'aller en prison oui oui je
veux aller en prison je mérite d'aller
en prison et ensuite il dit j'ai
étranglé j'ai tué l'enfant alors
l'enfant n'est pas mort heureusement on
espère qu' qu'il va s'en sortir donc il
a la garde et comme vous l'avez dit il
monte donc sur son téléphone il a pris
une une photo de de du moment où il il
il il étrangle
l'enfant on voit sa main on voit sa main
en photo où il étrangle l'enfant et il
dit euh j'ai serré l'fant F dans mes
bras et puis voilà ce qui s'est passé je
l'ai étranglé mettez-moi en prison je
l'ai tué il y a du sang partout et
cetera donc heureusement que les
policiers ont réagit très vite alors il
dit ça et il dit je l'ai abandonné dans
une voie et au moment où les policiers
réagissent heureusement que des riverins
ont trouvé les fameuses deux sacoches
avec le le l'enfant qui n'était pas mort
mais qui était très très tuméfié dans
ces sacoches quoi les riverins ont
réagit promptement alors il a été bien
entendu directement placé en garde à vue
pour tentative d'homicide sur mineur de
moins de 15 Ansou et il a indiqué au
policiers une adresse approximative ce
que je comprends pas est ce que doivent
se poser comme question les les
téléspectateurs c'est que ça fait 3 ans
qu'il était donc babysitter de cet
enfant il avait bien euh que les parents
le connaissaient et cetera donc il avait
bien une adresse on a l'imession bien
sûr oui la police a trouvé son adresse
il y a eu une perquisition ils ont saisi
tout son matériel informatique euh je
sais pas euh en tout cas ils ont trouvé
son adresse et ils y ont fait une
perquisition ça il y a pas de il y a pas
de difficulté là-dessus il avait il
habitait à vitrisène pas très loin de
l'endroit où habita
l'enfant il avait ses habitudes mais
c'est c'est une vie très très monacale
il avait pas pas de compagne pas d'amis
pas de vie sociale pas de vie sexuelle
enfin il venait de perdre sa mère ou il
avait non il a pas connu sa mère il
venait de perdre son
père c'est c'est un personnage c'est
c'est un profil très très particulier
alors il a été donc le parquet de
crétail a ouvert lundi une information
judiciaire pour tentative d'homicide
volontaire sur mineur de 15 ansoui il a
été placé en détention provisoire le
parquet a réagi vite ce matin il a été
placé en détention provisoire j'ajoute
simplement à toutes les précisions de
Michel que apparemment ce jour-là il
était
alcoolisé touture oui oui il était ivre
quand il est arrivé au commiss est-ce
que est-ce que c'est une récurrence
est-ce
que non non mais on attend
l'irresponsabilité la bouffée délirante
et tout ça on attend la suite oui oui
alorsoui vous dites bah oui c'est
effectivement ça alors bon pour le
moment il a été placé en détention il
est il a avoué son geste
donc il y a quand même un processus il
est entre guillemets divis parce qu'il
avait pas été condamné mais il avait
déjà été mis en cause donc je je pense
pas que sil y a non mais je pense pas
que sil y a non j'ai dit il est pas
resté div en tout cas il y aura pas une
irresponsabilité tout de suite mais
justement alors justement la question
que qu'on se pose à 21h10 on espère tous
que l'enfant va s'en sortir bien sûr
c'est le principal oui est-ce que ça va
changer quelque chose par rapport ah bah
oui oui tentative de meurtre et meurtre
c'est pas c'est pas du tout la même
chose c'est ça qui est fou parce que
pour moi pour moi pour moi c'est ça qui
est fou parce que c'est on espère tous
que l'enfant va s'en sortir mais en fait
c'est c'est c'est c'est incroyable parce
que lui il avait l'intention de le tuer
puisquil a dit j'ai tué un enfant entre
entre la tentative de meurtre et le
meurtre on est entre 30 ans et
perpétuité donc on n'est pas non plus
dans des peines ridicules alors juste
autre info qui est importante il s'est
présenté donc comme auxiliaire parental
il a rencontré directement un psychiatre
depuis sa garde à vue et elle a été
prolongée de 24 heures donc il a vu un
psychiatre direct c'est par rapport à ce
que dis tout de suite obligatoire quand
ouais tout de suite dans ces cas-là
examen psychiatrique pour voir dans quel
état il est pour pouvoir notifier tout
ça et surtout que ça puisse servir après
ultérieurement parce que si prétexte un
coup de folie une absence totale de
discernement le psychiatre pourra dire
pas du tout il était cohérent ou
confirmé c'est très important le
psychiatre en garde à vue c'est
uniquement pour voir silard s'il est
compatible avec la garde à vue et
ensuite il y a un expert psychiatre qui
va sur commission ratoire le l'analyser
l'expertiser fol dans quelle éta est
l'enfant aujourd'hui c'est important
alors le le selon les dernières
informations le le parquet n'a pas donné
de d'éclaircissement sur l'état de santé
c'est ce que j'avais des nouvelles et il
va très mal ah oui oui oui il va très
mal enfin en tout cas il est il est
entre la vie et la mort pr pronostic
vital engagé et on ne sait absolument
pas à l'heure où je vous parle on ne
sait absolument pas s'il va s'en sortir
il il a eu quoi comme comme comme
blessure il étit roué de coup c'est
c'est c'est une plaie ce gosse il a il a
été roué de coup au point
il était couvert de sang uniquement avec
à frapper avec ses ses mains et ses
pieds c'est c'est un truc de fou si vous
voulez je sais que vous aimez pas les
fous mais enfin que vous voulez les
juger mais peu importe c'est c'est
vraiment une une séquence de d'une rare
violence et cet enfant c'est un petit un
petit garçon il a 7 ans c'est pas c'est
pas résistant évidemment et il a il est
il est été plongé dans le coma et est
toujours pas sorti du coma et d'ailleurs
à tel point qu'on n pas pu vérifier s'il
avait été agressé sexuellement parce que
pour l'instant c'est pas l'heure de de
de de regarder ça c'est c'est l'heure
c'est de d'essayer de le sauver mais oui
et étranglé étrangl étranglé he étranglé
la tête plongée dans ces sacoches
abominable quoi tout c'est une d'une
violence une scène épouvantable c'est
une scène terrible les les les
enquêteurs juste il aurait fait ça où
dans dans dans la rue ou alors ça on
sait pas euh
le fait que cet enfant soit en caleçon
je pense qu'il était dans un lieu un peu
protégé parce que déjà un enfant en
caleçon dans la rue au mois de novembre
ça passerait pas inaperçu et avec ces
scènes de violence encore moins donc on
peut imaginer un Porsche un un hold
meuble il éit avec son vélo électrique
on pense bien sûr aux parents et voilà
on espère que cet enfant va s'en sortir
mais vous dit on voit des trucs de fou
c'est c'est complètement incroyable
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
tout de suite magéon sur C V merci à
tous